how's it going resume Panama and welcome
back to another episode of Deadpool my
merica dammit I can't think of any good
dick jokes I guess those people won't be
[ __ ] around anymore
ha ha ha ha ha who are you supposed to
be ok let's keep playing this is nicer
than my apart actually you know what we
should buy let's buy these bang leaves
Hayes I never try them
my favorite Ninja Turtles had these his
name was Rafael I don't know what
pitchforks is that what they called not
really let's tie them up
that's shotgun everything well whoa holy
shake they don't do a lot of damage
because we haven't upgraded that was
still there pretty badass haha hey hey
oh hey stop
well then fool never nice I care about
you in your life being dead
[ __ ] sake there we go I love them they
became spaghetti stop ah
Shan I broke my combo you don't bear you
victim I swim
thank you my golfer
hey you're not the whole that's Polizzi
Oh chef haha that guy [ __ ] huh
nope not today sir well [ __ ] yeah the
Hammers for life I don't overthink it
it's a hammer dota we're thinking hammer
time hammer the hammer was still the
spoon I'm overthinking at this place
really went to hell
wait what happened Knight what always
happens in prison you got tired of the
food they give food in prison thought
they'd let them [ __ ] my god what the
[ __ ]
hahahaha I need to make a quick phone
call we ran out of money again probably
hater stead pool what the hell is high
Moon going to my game well give some
money I transferred to your account a
transmission now loading ah okay I
should prefer did before it wasn't good
[ __ ] they got from one punch damn
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I love this game honestly
like the game please it's fun people
complaining that it's like repetitive
and stuff like that maybe it is but at
the same time like you have not played
alleys manners return if you're
complaining about the game feeling being
Saturday honestly it's not that bad and
it's also like a lot of critics are
really harsh on the game but it's like
the game doesn't even take itself
seriously you're not enjoying it
properly
like making I don't know I'm not saying
it's excusable some parts guess cuz it
doesn't take you seriously but at the
same time you can't just be a Legos this
gamers have these news made Nick the
game is just for fun anyway and that's
how you should enjoy it so it's it's
their loss if people are being harsh on
it but it's only only the critics the
players that score are actually not bad
at all
pretty high actually and where the [ __ ]
am I going what does that even mean
don't over think I'll wearing the prison
for it okay I got you I like where this
is going
yeah I think this is an easter egg even
I heard about this you're supposed to
follow the the disco sound or maybe not
no this is normal okay baby is that what
I think it is this was Patrick no no
never be shut it shut up we gotta get
down there but yeah I'm telling you it's
a trick of so shut up don't ruin this
what you saw you wouldn't be saying that
that makes no sense
we just gotta blend in you saw yeah yeah
this is my town
I like the red carpeting but what what's
been a while there better be tense Shawn
what is going on here uh unbreakable
glass
I demand gen8 it's about time someone
recognized the need to throw us apart
yes look
there's rope oh my god oh my god
mingle [ __ ] yeah we're gonna mingle fine
device
saddle up to this waterhole yes now
that's more like what I wasn't talking
you ah get away
who was she talking to them waters
qualify as an easter egg morning ladies
Hana he's around here I'd say yes
okay let's mingle around hey girl what's
up you coming often sorry I totally told
her this wasn't gonna be a hot party
says she didn't come
thank god she's not cool enough to hang
out with I fell asleep just 2% body fat
I mean really oh my god the conversation
is so cliche Traxxas almost painful okay
again I know how my shotguns becomes the
goal then [ __ ] awesome
we're gonna smooth toggle beginning it's
for the achievements I don't care the
team is I want the end yes I have to my
name is Deadpool perhaps you've heard of
me
star of the game that you're currently
in oh yeah don't you have your own
reality show game I got a game it's
better
so how to make out how do you make out
no wait why not
I'm in the game cap damn it what are
these [ __ ] balloons doing here anyway
okay what about you guys hi Helen irises
nice shot care for a drink
hi dad pool nice muscles ladies hello
mine repeat compliments this party is
awesome thank you my moon studious worm
oh no we don't have time for her
so what are the chances I could get to
play here
oh go away we're not in - dude watch
your sweet cheeks
yeah yeah that's great why does it have
to be so hard anyway so if I flip a coin
what a my chances of getting tail
six out of eight how many [ __ ] hours
where well sir we did it back in 83
[ __ ] so
I know right I thought you were dead
isn't that gambit the heck is he doing
here
trying to muscle in on our action what a
card and I'm fine
we miss one girl maybe this one okay
all right [ __ ] it bro devil
what are you don't waste your time with
her Oh Oh daddy likes just wait honey
I'm about to blow you away she's gonna
explode us what yeah
no no fake titty hell you mean this
whole party was just in our head
surprise ah sister's got pledged oh
you're gonna pay for that
come on why do you have to change the
weapon oh my gum stem now we need to
find a cable we need to reconnect that
wire somehow with all the rubber haha
huh first we're gonna upgrade our no not
you
Oh baby oh baby oh I'm gonna do it Oh
nice ass ha ha ha ha ha beautiful I
think that's how electricity works uh
what's going on on bag too darn near
kill them what what recomm darn you joy
uh-huh bringing the suspension of
disbelief what not what did that
electrifies with porno moustaches oh my
god we have so much in common
where do you suppose blockbuster took
road maybe he's trying to make her fall
in love with him yeah work on exactly
shape [ __ ]
yeah you're right Rocky's gonna tour her
killer said are you got okay
he sounds like [ __ ] Smeagol hello wow
this is really really freaky I could
swear I know you from somewhere
can we go to law school together you
lose right away Nolan for love where are
we hmm smells like our bathroom back
home oh that can't be good
hey there's wrote hi oh there's gonna be
food trucks across this this river of
[ __ ] ah that is not sink sink
I'd jump do that again know what why we
close our bubbles look jump across
well is it ah it's [ __ ] stupid
why not oh really did the thumbs too
what happens if we lined in this [ __ ]
I'm curious
feels pretty good I'm getting [ __ ] by
that okay
there is a lot of sewage down here for
what Chris I mean really what are you
doing that pole don't be stuck that pool
this is a fine school [ __ ] pool that's
what this place is also the smell
Oh what am i doing with my life Oh
nearly
okay
hahaha
what it's better be good congratulations
you got we upgraded your teleport
ability who cares and joy I'll take it
good enough already
wonder I stopped playing junior P geez
because they don't give you [ __ ] no
laughter get in your color board where I
go in to upgrade um some [ __ ] area Oh
sounds like what to happen to a nicer
bunch of guys you know we should
probably explain to the player how our
teleporter works
it runs on kitten farts oh no really
all the know out there will want to know
fine
well the purposes of creating an
entertaining mechanic that players can
employ to achieve an optimal amount of
fun factor limit at my LaPorta to a
shorter range than usual ah no wait what
mr. sugar buddy you taking me to rogue I
guess so how the [ __ ] does he know where
we are
checklist pain run run what I I for all
you nerds out there getting all puffy
over the fact that rogue in the comics
currently does not have the power to fly
you can officially move out of your
parents basement get a job and a life
and maybe maybe just maybe yo Kissin
yeah she flies an hour game okay nice
game hold on I've got an idea what is it
rogue will be so impressed what'd I say
so player
you coming or what sorry sorry I was
move that camera dying me oh how does
camera yes I'm yes I found you how to
grow up real - nice I got a good ass
shot going tink bombs
alright only two more to go right a how
do we get the bombs ah oh sweet oh dude
[ __ ] hell man alright I'm editing
this in my underwear and I forgot to do
an outro in the video so we're gonna do
it like this today leave a like if you
enjoyed watching Bros it really helps me
out a lot
hit subscribe to become a bread today
and I will see you in the next one it
comes to brofist it could come anywhere
coming up your body
you